[Musique]
bonjour bonjour alors c'est ça
maintenant à nouveau l'être
allez on passe à autre chose tu en
penses quoi ton battle alors là on gagne
les compétitions va pas se leurrer mais
pourquoi tu es aussi sûr de toi parce
que j'ai des goûts surdimensionné je me
fais une fellation chaque soir avant de
me coucher
ouais t'as pas pris la grosse tête par
hasard absolument pas c'est quoi ton
astuces pour faire autant de vues sur
tes vidéos
en fait c'est ça il faut juste mettre la
musique en très bonne qualité bien
enregistré au montage et faire les
changements de plans et même 6 nuls ça
paraîtra moins nul c'est ce qu'aiment
les vidéos c'est que c'est de la merde
mais vu que je fais des zooms ça paraît
beaucoup moins nuls et quel est le pire
commentaires de taschen celui de talent
que ce touché quand tu l'as lu on dirait
un coton-tige mixé avec une paire de
testicules je suis désolé mais c'est la
vérité
weight a réagi comment c'est à ça je me
suis inscrit à la salle de musculation
un essai sous forme d'abonnement donc tu
paies tous les mois pour pouvoir y aller
et j'y suis allée seule fois en trois
mois mais ça a poussé un peu un bain
c'est à dire que c'est pas vraiment un
brin c'est un bras qui sort du moule que
j'ai créé tu vois à on peut ajouter les
muscles nous mêmes on peut dire ici je
veux un muscle qui qui va dans ce sens
et ici je vais un muscle qui va dans ce
sens ouais c'est exactement ça regarde
j'ai plusieurs tests en stock
ça c'est abusé mais j'espère si votre
ferme ce cas je commence à transpirer
mon gars ok ce que tu aura alors un
petit mode ça pour la belgique
ici on a la meilleure mousse de rempl
[Musique]